شرعت Joy Sul العملية المطورة حديثًا في إطلاق الصواريخ الموجهة
الصاروخ الجديد الموجه النقي المطوَّر حديثًا هو النواة
إذا تم استخدام التكنولوجيا ، فسيتم استخدام المبلغ الإجمالي لمسار البقرة لمسافة 600 كيلومتر من أزياء بونغ مثل Joe Itsumo.
لقد أصبت هدفًا محددًا مسبقًا مثل الضوضاء
بعد الإطلاق السهل ، يتحدث طلاب وزارة الدفاع الوطني بصراحة ، من الداخل والخارج ، كثيرًا.
لأنها كانت ناجحة
في كثير من الأحيان يكون ريك على حق ، 8 دقائق من الأرض المحفزة تعطي صهيون وإيزي 8 4 خلال الدورة
تستخدم بالفعل من قبل الصواريخ الموجهة الأخرى
قوس الخوف من الحورية على ارتفاع منخفض
تم الكشف عن أن الخصائص المدارية من نوع بيون تم تأكيدها أيضًا.
لحظة صغيرة عندما أمر الدفاع الوطني والسياسات المحلية بأمر 8 د
يقال أن تطوير نظام الأسلحة هذا هو تعزيز لدينا gonsal و
بعد عدم احتساب الرتبة الثانية لكل وجود عسكري في شبه الجزيرة الكورية ،
تم تقييمه ليكون لديه مرافقة وصلت